So we can get to the workflow in the setup. So if we
go into the setup and then type in workflow into the quick find,
we should be able to create a new
workflow right here. Just click on Workflow Rules.
>> What is workflow?
>> And so, yeah. Here breaks down the different actions
that we can do, and like certain tasks that you
might be able to automate. But, we don't, we don't
need to go through this. We can just do it ourselves.
>> Yeah, that's what you're here for. To explain
these things. don't show me this page again. Actually.
>> Maybe.
[LAUGH]
When I'm not here.
>> Yeah.
>> Great. So, the first thing we want to do is create a new rule.
But, before we create that rule, let's
think about what we're trying to automate.
>> So, I want to automate the whole repair process.
>> Mm-hm.
>> You know, you file a maintenance ticket.
And then I want to automatically alert a technician.
>> Right. And so, a technician is just a user in our
organization. So we have two options. We can assign them a task.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And so when they first log in to
Salesforce, on their home tab they'll see all the open
tasks that they need to complete.
>> Cool.
>> And then we can also send them an email.
So automatically generate an email
with information about that maintenance ticket.
>> Nice, let's do it.
>> So, great.